[Music]
okay so blackbeard might be the smartest
character in one piece yes i know that
just like luffy he often does very
impulsive and foolish things like for
example almost being wiped out
completely by magellan and impul down
but when you really think about it
marshall dtg had a plan that was over 20
years in the making and he executed it
perfectly basically playing the entire
world which i just really have to
respect he joined whitebeard as a
teenager already with the intention to
get his hands on the most powerful logia
devil fruit the yamiyami no me he then
waited patiently on board of the yonko's
ship keeping his head low and biting his
time all that despite being ridiculously
powerful all the while remember he was
able to hurt shanks one of these
strongest people out there
[Music]
so instead of showing off his powers he
kept a low profile already recruiting
people for his future crew until finally
one of his crewmates actually got his
hands on the devil fruit he was hunting
for then he took his chance killed his
crewmate of over 20 years and left the
crew i mean yeah of course he did leave
the crew i'm already really impressed
with the patience this man had just like
luffy he always trusts in fate to find a
way for him somehow and as far as i can
remember it has always pretty much
worked out for him so far but the next
phase of his plan is even more
impressive and i can't believe i haven't
put one and one together in my head so
far because when you think about it
blackbeard basically orchestrated all of
the major events in the story so far
maybe that was obvious to you but to me
that actually blew my mind a little bit
think about it blackbeard's goal after
finally consuming his ultimate devil
fruit was going for the one piece right
away for that he needed to join the
yonko and become a force to compete with
the likes of kaido and big mom so what
does he do well obviously he decides to
get the strongest crew possible and if
you don't have the patience and charisma
of luffy or are as romantically active
as big mom blackbeard figured that he'd
just grab himself the strongest people
available to him that are basically out
of work right now
[Music]
but how to get into the most secure
place on the entire planet except maybe
for marijuana easiest answer pretty
straightforward ally yourself with the
world government so they basically
invite you in so now blackbeard's first
step is becoming a warlord as you'll
remember he thinks about hunting down
luffy to get on the good side with the
marines but fails luffy after all just
like him is special something that
blackbeard by the way knows really
really well and so fate offers him a
different solution i'm of course talking
about ace who was hunting after
blackbeard to bring him to justice
once he realizes that ace is intent on
bringing him back to whitebeard a new
opportunity opens up for him he realizes
that not only can he use ace as a
bargaining ship to become a warlord but
he can even orchestrate everything so
that the marines will take on his former
captain after all teach also always had
his eyes on the strongest paramecia
whitebeard's gouda gurangnumi he knew
that he would have to get past the man
at some point anyway not only to reach
the one piece but also for the devil
fruit and now he had all the cards he
needed to play his big rounds okay so he
delivers ace to the government receiving
the status of a warlord he then enters
impel down gathers all the powerful
people he wants into his crew and then
leaves directly for marine fort where
the marines and whitebeard's army had
already weakened each other
significantly
and so walking in there with his army of
legendary pirates he takes advantage of
the situation kills whitebeard and takes
his devil fruit only fleeing when shanks
arrives now finally he has become a
yonko and is now able to seriously go
after the one piece being at least on
eye level with even the most powerful
people in the one piece world all of
that based on a plan that he made as a
16 year old i mean if that doesn't make
him one of the most genius characters in
the story i don't know what to tell you
actually i do if you want weekly
one-piece content just like this
subscribe right now done nice as a
reward i'll tell you a super new black
bit theory in this video as well now
teach is still a bit of a mystery
there's just so little that we actually
know about him and even though i do love
myself some teaser mystery i'm a very
simple man i still want to try and
figure out as much about blackbeard as
possible today did you for example know
that blackbeard's favorite food is
cherry pie
now rightfully you might be wondering
what that has to do with anything aha
looks like we have a sponsor for this
video it's baksu who sent me this
awesome sleek and black mystery snack
box thank you boxxu for sponsoring this
video let's see what's inside bok su is
a monthly snack box subscription service
that delivers original assortments of
premium japanese snacks and tea pairings
directly from japan to wherever you live
so this is a grilled potato
let me sell some potato
what i really like about this is that
they collaborate with traditional
japanese family manufacturers that make
all of these snacks and candies so you
don't just get some random stuff you
could buy in any japanese supermarkets
but actual local stuff so this is a
great opportunity to try some authentic
japanese food and if you want to try
that for yourself you can get 10 of your
own boxes snack box and save up to 47
bucks using my code and link in the
description below i really have to put
these away though because i have
literally zero self-control when it
comes to sweets now you probably already
know that blackbeard is written as a
foil to luffy that means that both
characters share a lot of similarities
but are the exact opposite in many other
aspects if we're being honest teach is
probably luffy's biggest rival when it
comes to becoming pirate king he is the
only antagonist in the story where i'm
really concerned for luffy and the other
straw heads when the battle between the
two undoubtedly will happen because
blackbeard shares two of luffy's most
important traits believing in his dream
and trusting in fate to guide him the
only thing blackbeard doesn't have is
luffy's compassion for others he is
cunning meticulous patient manipulative
and cheats his way to what he wants
while luffy is oblivious reckless
impulsive selfless and often takes the
burden upon himself in order to
accomplish what he really wants now oda
basically smashes the similarities and
polar opposites into our face during
their first meeting on jaya
there is just so much symbolism in just
this one scene here so i decided to make
an entire video about it that i strongly
encourage you to watch after this one
luffy's and blackbeard's journeys are
the exact opposite of each other but
what i found the most interesting thing
however is that both of them wouldn't be
where they are today without the other
luffy begins his journey by obtaining a
seemingly weak devil fruit through a
father-like relationship with a yonko
meanwhile blackbeard begins his journey
by stealing a strong devil fruit by
breaking his father-like relationship
with another yonko
teach banishes waffle from drum island
and leaves it as a nation without a king
while luffy banishes wahpo from drum
island as well but leaves it as a brand
new nation with a new king and as a
result luffy can recruit chopper luffy
sails through the first half of the
grand line taking down the shichibukai
blackbeard sails through the first half
of the grand line hoping to become one
but only when luffy actually takes out
crocodile does blackbeard get his chance
luffy declares war on the world
government while blackbeard joins it
luffy later infiltrates impel down in
order to rescue ace who was caught by
blackbeard who is only successful in
recruiting all the level 6 pirates
because of the rebellion that luffy has
started earlier however on the other
hand luffy is only able to enter and
influence the war at all because
blackbeard's crew had hypnotized the
staff who control the gates of justice
when leaving the prison luffy uses his
astonishing will to recover from
magellan's poison and blackbeard cheats
and relies on an antidote to do the same
and then there's of course marineford
itself where luffy's will is completely
broken while blackbeard's will is
vindicated the lowest point of our hero
is the highest of his antagonist even
the way they become yonko is completely
opposite blackbeard defeated a weakened
whitebeard and the remnants of his
scattered crew while luffy will defeat a
fully powered kaido and his entire army
of beast pirates
[Music]
okay now we all know that blackbeard
will be the major antagonist on left
tail however as we know there is an even
bigger villain to defeat in the story
emu who i made this massive theory hear
about in case you haven't watched it yet
blackbeard is a villain yes but he also
lives with the exactly same mentality
that luffy does he wants freedom above
all else and he also believes in the
dreams of a new age so blackbeard
embodies the same path as luffy but he
will ultimately lose because luffy is
reaching the top of the world the
quote-unquote right way
okay so what's the takeaway here it's
that blackbeard is one of the most
influential characters in the story
someone instilled the idea of the yami
yaminomi in his head as a kid and just
like luffy he spent his whole life
aiming to become pirate king and of
course this wouldn't be a proper
blackbeard video if we didn't theorize
at least a little bit or actually a lot
the big question is of course where
blackbeard got his drive from who told
him about the yami yaminomi and why does
he actually want to become pirate king
at this point i think it would be pretty
surprising if blackbeard was not related
to rox diese back at least in some whale
form since blackbeard and luffy mirror
each other that means that blackbeard
also shares not only the concept of
dreams but also that of inherited will
with our protagonists
and so when you consider how shanks
inspired luffy's journey seeing in him
the one who could inherit roger's will
it would make a lot of sense if luffy's
major competitor would inherit the will
of roger's biggest threats
and not only has teach made beehive
island rox's former headquarters the
center of his operation but he even
named his main ship after the man whose
name no one is supposed to really know
the sabre of sabacc i mean sengoku cesso
himself most people today don't even
know that rocks existed and those that
do only remember him as rocks not his
last name sebeck so i think it's pretty
clear that blackbeard must have had a
personal connection more at least a deep
fascination with the man i know what
you're thinking now so is blackbeard
roxas son now timeline wise i think this
would work out pretty well blackbeard is
40 years old and grew up as an orphan
rox was killed 38 years ago i think so
this would mean that blackbeard was two
years old when rox died and should rox
have been his father his death would
leave the two-year-old blackbeard on his
own and honestly i think it's quite
possible that blackbeard genuinely
resented whitebeard for leaving his
father to die well
a surprising character that might give
us some hints at teacher's backstory is
actually a roachie yes i know no one
wants to talk about orochi but listen to
this orochi was born to the prosecuted
kudozumi clan one of the six royal
families of wano interestingly enough
korozumi is the only family whose name
does not have the kanji for moon in it
instead it translates into black
charcoal and so through backstabbing and
trickery orochi has climbed his way into
a position that is not his not only that
but he has killed and betrayed the
people who took him in all in the name
of revenge and even more than that he
has demonstrated himself to be a coward
in the face of danger and death
[Music]
and i hope you'll agree that this
parallels blackbeard pretty nicely even
though he's a member of the d-clan he
doesn't share much of the classical d
traits i mean they're all strongly
willed positive individuals with a stark
sense of compassion and loyalty laughing
in the face of death both orochi and
blackbeard also executed and ridiculed
the very person who took them in while
broadcasting the event life we know that
blackbeard doesn't sleep and neither did
orochi as a kid claiming that he was too
scared both of them getting handed
strong devil fruit powers to secure
their position so could orochi's
prosecution and quest for revenge be a
hint at blackbeard's childhood for being
the son of the most dangerous man on the
planet and of course i also want to talk
about blackbeard's ability to have
multiple devil fruits and i have a
theory i bet you didn't hear yet now
there are a few really popular ideas
already out there one is that it's a
special feature of the yama yamino me to
absorb powers however given how
notorious the fruit is it's very
unlikely that the gorosei wouldn't know
about it same goes for the server's
fruit theory though i do like that a bit
more a new theory i really enjoyed and
that you might have heard about is that
blackbeard is actually a squid who have
three hearts and eight arms just like
the three heads and eight crossbones on
the jolly roger however i've stumbled
across another theory i don't think i've
seen discussed anywhere before even
though i sadly don't know the author
blackbeard might be inspired by the
barbarossa brothers or the redbeard
brothers the story goes like this there
were three brothers the mother was named
katarina same as blackbeard's crewmate
the older one was a pirate while his two
younger brothers were working with their
father after his father's death the two
brothers joined the eldest one and
became pirates with him under the
crescent moon flag and coincidentally
katarina devon is called the crescent
moon hunter the number three is closely
connected to blackbeard he has three
guns and his pirate flag features three
skulls and we all know that a pirate
flag describes the captain pretty
perfectly and of course we have this
notorious scene on jaya
as i explained in detail in my scene
analysis of this the blackbeard that
luffy meets in the bar and the one that
he meets outside are clearly different
people luffy doesn't recognize the man
he fought with about cherry pies and
both him and zorro clearly state that
blackbeard is multiple people also
remember this moment from impel down
blackbeard says that luffy's haki has
improved but he would only know that if
luffy had actually used it on jaya in
other words him and zorro unconsciously
use their observation haki here all
riled up from the fight back in the bar
okay so here is the twist blackbeard has
two other twin brothers there are three
black beards in total and so when he ate
the yami yaminomi that is explicitly
shown as capable of absorbing humans as
well he was joined by his two brothers
just as in the barbarossa story and so
he hit his two brothers inside him which
might explain why blackbeard was still
eating the pie when luffy already left
the bar kiss it was a different brother
either that or he just eats like hell
which i admit is also entirely possible
having three different people would also
explain the varying personalities teach
this place
[Music]
[Laughter]
he had to cover himself up to let his
brother out and had him eat whitebeard's
fruit and when you saw blackbeard in
marineford with two different powers one
in each hand the hand that uses
whitebeard's ability wasn't actually
teacher's hand it was his brother's
teach used the yami yaminomi to pull his
hand inside him and let his brother's
hand out so if you believe that he used
one different devil fruit with each half
of his body i think you're wrong teach
has the guragura power in his right hand
the yami yami in his left hand and now
look at this here the yummy yummy is now
in his right hand and he uses the
guragura one with his left hand and now
if you look really closely at
blackbeard's right hand and compare it
to this one the rings in his right hand
have disappeared now this could of
course be oda being a bit sloppy here
with a drawing but what if it's not
don't you also ever get the feeling that
teach kind of looks a bit different
whenever we see him could that just be
the other brothers now this may sound a
bit weird but i feel like the biggest
giveaway we have to this are actually
his teeth no matter how many panels i
compared different versions of
blackbeard have different levels of
dental hygiene i guess one has a lot of
gaps one just a few and this one here
doesn't have any at all now it's only in
the manga but it's definitely
deliberately done there is the super
cruel one with a complete set of teeth
that we see an impul down then there is
the one with one middle tooth that we
meet in the bar on jaya and finally
there is one with two gaps on the top
right which is the most common version
and thus i would guess the teach that
ate the yummy yummy nomi he ate the
strongest slogia his brother ate the
strongest paramecia by transferring the
fruit in the same way as shown on punk
hazard and now there is a third brother
left and he'll probably eat the
strongest mythical zone now if you
really want to fully understand how
important blackbeard is however i
strongly recommend that you check out my
scene analysis with him and luffy right
here
thanks for watching